like literally they they gave us the
vote so they could just get the
propaganda on the radio and all that
so they could do whatever they
wanted to the society and they but they
use everybody they use sure they're
they're weaponizing women against men
right now to keep everyone distracted
but every but they've also like
minorities too yeah minority but but
it's it's it's everybody it's like like
we we went from like slavery where we're
no there's no longer any slaves but
there's we're economic slaves we working
and stuff so they they all right we'll
let the we'll let the slaves cuz they
still think almost everybody even
everyone in this room they think we're
all still slaves really just we just all
these are just my tax cattle surfs and
stuff like I mean this is why a mortgage
is like why is it why is your when you
buy a house it's called a mortgage
because it's going to take you until you
die to pay that off m